hello and welcome to this video playing
ESO call yeah this is one of my
opponents may have a terrible squat
minus 5 and and I remember those games
and many of them I had nice positions
but screwed up akhe for is supposed to
be good let's see ya white gets pin and
I sent again this position but black is
hoping that my slightly weakened King
position is helping him let's see what
happens I remember from those games that
i held against him that I had time for
had a time problems and everything yeah
he's playing very quickly so let's see
here Bishop g6 Bishop h3 that's not take
c3 so I know that actually does not work
I'd have to 57
let's see probably has to go i 5 mm yeah
I don't know if that's good yeah but its
aggressive try to use this awkward
situation on the diagonal on the h3 dd7
diagonal hmm I don't know does he have
to give material here possible I'm
threatening Bishop age six and taking on
f5
okay so he's attacking d4 here
okay I'll take this check very very
tough dispositional very sharp okay but
if i take here yes to go to f7 I think
I'll do that let's take the ship f7 and
now hmm at Bishop he is very strong I'd
like to get rid of that somehow but will
be difficult to do okay let's put this
in the middle of the board i'm also
threatening community forum just a
little trick but you never know Queen 22
maybe next to checking age 6
yeah I want to be relatively quick here
because I definitely remember i have
screwed up on time against them before
so I'm taking this don't see why not I'm
threatening f6 now winning which she
ignores okay I special b6 okay this is
probably playable but what about Knight
f6 in this position threatening mate if
he is the TA check check kingi 8 to 1
and Abbott a twins material I think
you
can prove that yeah now look g1 Bishop
g6 I can go back and win the Bishop to
g5 but also to h4 would work it's maybe
better probably not a big difference
now he s who has to do that allow that
an end game but i wonder if i can do
better than the endgame be covering it
it's an attack it's also just an attack
let's see if I can keep the Queen's on
you I hope I'm not playing too
complicated here for my own good ok so I
have to have to track twins I mean it's
an endgame a piece up after all so night
f5 fear takes on g6 write a five I take
on g6 all right at the end h3 is hanging
hmm doesn't seem totally clear baby
let's do this data I'm getting at the
clock run down to low here he can take
with the fop actually it's a little bit
it wasn't planned that's what I'm trying
to say mmm 95 isn't even that clear lam
okay haha anyway so I'm I have problems
against this guy
the weird thing is it is actually not
easy I mean it's not like I have a super
simple Winnie relief
as pawns I'm quite compact and my pawns
are weak all of them
a5 I didn't expect ok check all right
it's really difficult I bishop he is
doing nothing I will look C 2 i'm just
playing stupid Morsi
I'm actually happy with I can draw now
somehow but okay I've got some attacking
chance assume we need to whomp
you
check-check
ruge f2 or something like that Jeff
black forfeits on time okay he profited
on time I don't know there was a weird
game and it was I don't know I had held
technically somewhat difficult maybe I
should have just I don't know like
something this should be just very easy
F 4x4 system and forth just winning not
go for the end game I mean okay there
the end game should win but yeah I made
a mid life very difficult for myself
with 94 which was really a bad idea yeah
I can take Route 23 that stronger but
the whole reports they make they make it
difficult especially with no time check
now here checks probably equal somehow
did also what the engine is giving check
for some kind of perpetual some kind of
draws check and here check yeah from chi
towards the trauma team just gave gave
me this got to cut some what's got
somewhat slowly at the end so how did I
get this position this good position
after Knight c3 I think I probably
better here efore is given by the by the
stock fish Angeles even stronger
yeah I threatening it takes a five that
is just a stronger version of the game
that's it's very good for what now the
whole black opening is kind of dubious
and its really dubious not to put put
something back now we are night back to
have six or something like that you just
didn't did really a reactor to this Jan
yeah this is now it's very sharp 95
looks good threatening 24 so we cannot
just play this for example and I can
take an ID f6 though King back and now
does that look to all very normal and
then all of a sudden had this winning
position yeah this is this is the thing
f6 is winning immediately what am I
doing here in those games f6 I you know
I'm threatening made and I'm still
attacking the Queen how simple do you
want to have it wow I mean okay there
are also wins but it's not it's not just
it is not over and lightly for is also
not stronger now as this I can just take
a while I really get so many
opportunities sometimes to win outright
and still make some kind of long game
out of it it's amazing okay thanks for
watching